Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
When we, humans look at an image, or a piece
of video footage, such as this one, we all
understand that this is just a 2D projection
of the world around us.
So much so, that if we have the time and patience,
we could draw a depth map that describes the
distance of each object from the camera.
This information is highly useful, because
we can use it to create real-time defocus
effects for virtual reality and computer games,
or even perform this Ken Burns effect in 3D,
or in other words, zoom and pan around in
a photograph, but, with a beautiful twist,
because in the meantime, we can reveal the
depth of the image.
However, when we show the same images to a
machine, all it sees is a bunch of numbers.
Fortunately, with the ascendancy of neural
network-based learning algorithms, we now
have a chance to do this reasonably well.
For instance, we discussed this depth perception
neural network in an earlier episode, which
was trained using large number input-output
pairs, where the inputs are a bunch of images,
and the outputs are their corresponding depth
maps for the neural network to learn from.
The authors implemented this with a random
scene generator, which creates a bunch of
these crazy configurations with a lot of occlusions
and computes via simulation the appropriate
depth map for them.
This is what we call supervised learning,
because we have all these input-output pairs.
The solutions are given in the training set
to guide the training of the neural network.
This is supervised learning, machine learning
with crutches.
We can also use this depth information to
enhance the perception of self-driving cars,
but this application is not like previous
two I just mentioned.
It is much, much harder, because in the earlier,
supervised learning example, we have trained
the network in a simulation, and then, we
also use it later in a computer game, which
is, of course, another simulation.
We control all the variables and the environment
here.
However, self-driving cars need to be deployed
in the real world.
These cars also generate a lot of video footage
with their sensors, which could be fed back
to the neural networks as additional training
data…if we had the depth maps for them,
which, of course, unfortunately, we don’t.
And now, with this, we have arrived to the
concept of unsupervised learning.
Unsupervised learning is proper machine learning,
where no crutches are allowed.
We just unleash the algorithm on a bunch of
data, with no labels, and if we do it well,
the neural network will learn something useful
from it.
It is very convenient, because any video we
have may be used as training data.
That would be great.
But we have a tiny problem, and that tiny
problem is that that this sounds impossible.
Or it may have sounded impossible, until this
paper appeared.
This work promises us no less than unsupervised
depth learning from videos.
Since this is unsupervised, it means that
during training, all it sees is unlabeled
videos from different viewpoints, and somehow,
figures out a way to create these depth maps
from it.
So how is this even possible?
Well, it is possible by adding just one ingenious
idea.
The idea is that since we don’t have the
labels, we can’t teach the algorithm how
to be right, but instead, we can teach it
to be consistent.
That doesn’t sound like much, does it?
Well, it makes all the difference, because
if we ask the algorithm to be consistent,
it will find out that a good way to be consistent
is to be right!
While we are looking at some results, to make
this clearer, let me add one more real-world
example that demonstrates how cool this idea
is.
Imagine that you are a university professor
overseeing an exam in mathematics, and someone
tells you that for one of the problems, most
of the students gave the same answer.
If this is the case, there is good chance
that this was the right answer.
It is not a 100% chance that this is the case,
but if most of the students have the same
answer, it is much more unlikely that they
all failed the same way.
There are many different ways to fail, but
there is only one way to succeed.
Therefore, if there is consistency, often
there is success.
And this simple, but powerful thought leads
to far-reaching conclusions.
Let’s have a look at some more results!
Wo-hoo!
Now this is something.
Let me explain why I am so excited for this.
This is the input image, and this is the perfect
depth map that is concealed from our beloved
algorithm and is there for us to be able to
evaluate its performance.
These are two previous works, both use crutches,
the first was trained via supervised learning
by showing it input-output image pairs with
depth maps, and does reasonably well, while
the other one gets even less supervision,
a worse crutch if you will, and it came up
with this.
Now, the unsupervised new technique was not
given any crutches and came up with this.
Holy mother of papers.
It looks like a somewhat coarser, but still,
very accurate version of the true depth maps.
So what do you know!
This neural network-based method just looks
at unlabeled videos, and finds a way to create
depth maps by not trying to be right, but
trying to be consistent.
This is one of those amazing papers where
one simple, brilliant idea can change everything
and make the impossible possible.
What a time to be alive!
What you see here is an instrumentation of
this depth learning paper we have talked about,
which was made by Weights and Biases.
I think organizing these experiments really
showcases the usability of their system.
Also, Weights & Biases provides tools to track
your experiments in your deep learning projects.
Their system is designed to save you a ton
of time and money, and it is actively used
in projects at prestigious labs, such as OpenAI,
Toyota Research, GitHub, and more.
And, the best part is that if you are an academic
or have an open source project, you can use
their tools for free.
It really is as good as it gets.
Make sure to visit them through wandb.com/papers
or just click the link in the video description
and you can get a free demo today.
Our thanks to Weights & Biases for their long-standing
support and for helping us make better videos
for you.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!